all right
good afternoon members and officers of
the council members of the public
welcome to the meeting of the
constitutional review working party bit
of housekeeping
fire evacuation procedure if the firearm
is activated please vacate the offices
via the stairs either through the
security doors or opposite the lifts in
the foyer please do not use the lifts
please assembly and holy square on the
green and officers will assist you and
advise you when it's deemed safe to
return
does anyone intend to film the meeting
no
i don't think there's any need for me to
carry on with that side as there's no
members of the public here can everybody
please ensure that their mobile phones
are turned to silent and they're not
used to make or receive calls in the
chamber while the meeting is in progress
please note this meeting is being live
stream for members of public except for
any item of business where exempt or
confidential and confidential
information is considered following the
exclusion of the present public from the
meeting
this meeting is also being recorded and
will be broadcast on the internet
with any member who wishes to speak
under council procedure rule 20.1 please
announce it now
are there any apologies for absence
apologies from cancer heart thank you
and are there any declarations of
interest
right i moved that the minutes of the
meeting held on the 11th of november
2021 be approved and signed as a correct
record
could i have a second or please
thank you councillor zepsky unless
anyone has any objections to the minutes
i will take them as agreed
thank you
item agenda four which is revision to
delegations and asked mr hughes the
committee services manager to present
the report
thank you chairman
this report is asking the
constitutional reworking party to
consider recommending
that we change the scheme of delegations
to authorise the chief executive to
declare vacancies in office under
section 86 of local government act 1972
so this is where um
a councillor has um
ceased to be a councillor via a number
of very specific uh reasons one of those
is that they have failed to attend a
meeting within a six-month period
another one could be that
they become employed by the council
another reason why a counselor may be um
disqualified they are
um
sentenced to or they committed a crime
in a sentence to a
prison sentence of more than three
months i think is another another one
so very specific
reasons
if a councillor passes away that
wouldn't be covered by this there'd be
no need to declare a vacancy in that
instance the vacancy is just there and
again if a councillor resigns that is
another reason why you wouldn't need to
declare a vacancy
so the form of three
what would happen is that the council
currently
would need to formally declare the
vacancy
at a council meeting
as a result of that you can then go on
and
organize the the resultant by-election
now
what we found is that
it can be seen as inefficient or untidy
or
unfair on the council involved
that there is a gap between
um
the event that has caused them to be
disqualified
and the point at which the depth rate
the vacancy is declared
that is quite uh untidy uh from a local
government point of view especially when
the law is very clear which is that the
council has no
real option in in declaring that vacancy
it must
i think it says it shall i think is the
correct word the council shall declare a
vacancy forthwith so there's no option
for the council when it considers it to
do anything else other than just declare
it
so what we're proposing is that those
the the power to declare a vacancy uh in
those specific reasons is delegated to
the chief executive that way the events
that causes the council to be
disqualified can happen
um and then the chief executive can then
declare the vacancy straight away after
that has happened that is then a neat
process because otherwise you might get
into a situation whereby
somebody is
um has recently happened where a
councillor ceases to be a member due to
non-attendance at meetings
but they then don't cease to be a
counsellor until the point that the the
vacancy is declared
so effectively you have this sort of
slightly
murky situation
that can be seen from outside in that
sense
um
so by doing this it makes it a lot
neater a lot fairer uh on both accounts
that are involved and makes the process
a lot more transparent so when we say a
counselor has been disqualified
they would be disqualified because the
chief executive would have declared the
vacancy
hopefully that's explained it happy to
take any questions
yeah just a quickie how long will the
chief executive have to declare that
vacancy
it's not really a a given period of time
uh it would be um
that she has the power to do that so she
would do it as soon as possible the law
is very clear that she has whoever does
it whether it's council or whether it
would be her if they use the word for
with
so there's not actually a there's not a
given time scale within the law they
have to do it as soon as possible
um that's the way the law is written if
that's helpful
thank you yeah um i mean on the facebook
it seems uh because it's a matter of
just executing the law pretty much it
seems like a reasonable idea but i just
wonder just thinking for your list could
there be any circumstances where
actually there could be a bit of debate
about whether there could be a gray area
about whether
it should be you know it actually is a
case of a council that needs you know
vacancy needs to be declared or not
because i just feel that if there were
any kind of debate then it'd be better
to leave an elected member's hand
i think
it's important to distinguish or to to
separate out
um the operation of the law
which is
and
the um
the
arguing about whether or not we think
somebody is disqualified or not i think
they would be quite different
um
i think that by doing it this way
there's an opportunity for those
discussions to be held
and for people to
um argue that us about it for for wants
of a better phrase
but i don't think it's a case of members
outside of the person involved
would be involved because it's not
really up to members as to whether that
person is disqualified
the law decides whether
that counselor is disqualified or not
um
so we would argue about that and discuss
that and make sure that that process um
the application of the law was was done
properly
and then we would announce that the
person had been disqualified and then
the declaration would be made
does that make sense is that
yeah um
yeah i think um
nick's explained it uh pretty well i
think what we're trying to say is i
think what you're
saying council hopkinson there might be
a situation where there's a debate as to
whether they have or they haven't
attended their element number of
meetings say for example in the
situation where we had recently
and what constitutes attending a
relevant meeting
but the the legislation was
changed a few years ago to be very
specific to say that it is six months
attendance from the date of the last
attendance prior to that change there
was some ambiguity to the wording so it
would be quite clear that you would look
back to the last date when they'd
attended and then you would count for
with six months and it's very clear that
it has to be a meeting where they are
part of the meeting so it's not just
them turning turning up to observe or
something like that so that would be the
situation it's quite clear-cut but there
may well be a bit of an argument as
there was recently as to what
constituted attending or whatever we
would get we would sort that out it
wouldn't be that
democratic services would say somebody
hasn't attended six months of meetings
and then madeleine would declare a
vacancy that's not how it would work but
it just means that once we've resolved
the argument
we don't have to wait until full council
because the problem at the moment we in
the last in the recent situation um
the vacancy isn't declared until it's
declared and without the delegation that
has to be at full council so you either
have to call an extraordinary council
meeting or you wait till the next
scheduled council meeting so this avoids
that problem so once we've got to the
point of decision
the um chief executive can declare it
but it's not she's not going to leap in
and start declaring left right and
center without without discussing it
with the relevant group leaders or
whatever i mean that just wouldn't
happen
thank you chair yeah i mean i'd just
like to um voice my support for this
having been through
a few years back
the situation we found ourselves in
there where actually members were voting
against
what was what is technically a lawful
act
to declare a vacancy and i think we had
to return to full council three times
for that particular occasion
um
i i think it's it's a it's a very
strange situation where members are
asked to come to a full council meeting
to vote on something that is the law
that they have to vote on
so this makes perfect sense to me and
like um
nick hughes said it's very
it's untidy if you do it any other way
it is very common across most councils
to have this in place and
it was probably unfortunate that we
didn't have it in place following
the event which i think was about i
can't even remember now a few years back
three years back so
fully endorse it also um there is
um the gap that is left um if we have to
wait for full council hearing
because obviously the that particular
award is probably without a functioning
counsellor
they might be very awkward for that
counselor to still perform their roles
in knowing that they're going to be
disqualified but they haven't
technically been disqualified so and
obviously there's also the financial
implications of the receiving of
allowance etcetera so
i think you're right this is very tidy
way of doing it and
just want to support it really in the
right way forward thank you
yeah i would just be interested i know
perhaps it's not maybe not appropriate
to go into the data as the individual
but i'd be interested in what the
dispute was about in that time because
the whole question for me is you know
are there times where it actually is a
matter of interpretation or is it as in
the example you mentioned is it actually
always really clear-cut so i'm just
interested in
that example how how did it come to pass
that there was three council meetings to
debate it if it was
i just wonder what the actual
issue was in that case i mean i
appreciate you might not be able to
recall over
i'm sorry can i just ask mr hughes is it
appropriate to discuss that bearing in
mind we are
recording and showing to the public
yeah so i
i don't think it's appropriate for us to
go into the details of that but i think
one of the other reasons that we want to
do this is that
um evidently when a counsellor is
disqualified
the party of which that counselor
belongs to
will be naturally extremely disappointed
that that's happened
um and then
not saying that it always happens but
then
politics can then come into
what is a relatively black and white
application of the law
and so
by allowing us to do this it takes that
temptation to go down that route
away if that's helpful
thank you yeah uh
i mean it's a non-debate anyway because
we come to council to declare the
vacancy we don't come to council to
determine whether or not the councillor
has been rightfully or wrongfully
disqualified that process takes place
beforehand our duty when we come to full
council is purely to vote the vacancy
so i think that's maybe where the
misconception came in that particular
instance that we had before
and um yes it doesn't we don't need to
go into detail but that is a prime
example of why this this actually makes
sense because members were voting on the
situation rather than voting on
declaring the vacancy which is two very
separate things so
so yeah thanks that's helpful because
then
so i can see that actually even in the
current situation it's not a matter of
members actually deciding how the law is
to be applied so it's not it so in that
case i don't see any reason to uh oppose
this suggestion
this the
proposal
thank you chairman so the leader of the
council has asked dem services to
propose a number of amendments to the
council procedurals regarding elements
of the leaders report
these are outlined in the report and
they're shown at annex one
so if i just
bring up annex one
so the proposed changes
are that um
the
leaders of other political groups so
if we just go through the process as it
stands at the moment
the leader sends the leaders report out
to the opposition group leaders
by close of business on the saturday
isn't it i think it is
before the meeting on the following
thursday
uh they then uh those opposition group
leaders um read the report they um come
up with their questions
they come along to council
the leader of the council reads her uh
leaders report out and then each lead
opposition leader in turn then asks
questions to the uh to the leader
she then has an opportunity to answer
those
um so the changes that we're proposing
is that the
leaders of the other political groups
must provide the leader and the chairman
with any questions that they intend to
ask as part of their response to the
leader speech
so we're asking them to submit in
advance the questions
this will allow the leader a better
chance to research questions and provide
a better answer on the evening
um
but obviously um
given the fact that the time scales are
quite short what we've had to do is
propose some slight tweaks to the um the
the
time line as it were
and these are shown in annex one so
we're suggesting now that the
leader provides her report
one week prior to the meeting so we're
moving it from the saturday to the
thursday so close of business by the
thursday
and then that the
leaders of the other political groups
should ask i should submit their
questions by close of business on the
tuesday prior to the meeting
okay
and that then gives the leader and her
team um chance to research the answers
um and and come up with an appropriate
response for the meeting on the thursday
so
any questions that were not submitted
by that tuesday deadline
um would be ruled as inadmissible by the
chairman because obviously he would have
got copied into the um response as we've
said earlier
if they were then raised as part of the
response to the leader speech so those
that propose changes i'm happy to take
any questions
obviously um i do have to declare sort
of slight interest in this even though
it's not probably a full declaration
um
if
committee members were to feel that this
was uh maybe a complicated way forward
um
because i am very conscious of the fact
that having to stand in the leaders
shoes on the night and
having prepared
the the report and sent it over to allow
five days
for
the group leaders to study it um
when the questions come back in you've
got a nano second really to work out
the reply
and
i think sometimes it could be um
there could be mistakes and maybe
misleading advice because you haven't
been given enough time to be able to
consider it but if members were to of
the committee and this is a sort of
counter proposal if you like if they
were uncomfortable with this approach
then the other approach could be
that the leader is allowed to deliver
their speech on the night or their
report on the night so that makes it a
level playing field between the leader
giving out their report versus the um
the group leaders to come back in with
their questions so it's a level playing
field so everybody's got the same amount
of time to be able to because without
doubt it's um
it
it can be uh the leaders report although
the leader is obviously trying to relay
what has been going on within the
council and what they've been doing
over the last
uh the period of time between the full
council meetings
it in some way is um
it can be a tool to um
uh
to expose some lack of knowledge or
whatever and it's just the fact that it
just allows everyone to have a level
playing field so
if members of the committee weren't um
and the chair weren't of a mind that
this was a complicated way forward that
would be maybe an alternative solution
to to level it up a little bit so that
uh
um
that everyone you know has a fair chance
at the same amount of time i mean i know
that that doesn't
um
preclude the argument that the leader
hasn't got enough time to prepare
responses but then it also means that
the the group leaders haven't got time
to to build in maybe
um sections of it that are
quite frankly sometimes impossible to
answer and give a genuine answer to so
um
i
i mean obviously i have a vested
interest in this but uh
it really is just the way of of you know
being able to report to council it's not
just because it's me i mean it happens
to any leader and i think that
you know that you you do need time to
prepare but then if you don't have time
to prepare to respond then it should be
the same for everybody coming back in so
it's just on how you feel about it but
it it it does feel a little bit once
when you're up there trying to answer it
does feel hellishly one-sided and um
it uh
is sometimes difficult to give an
accurate response and and and you don't
really want to not give an accurate
response so
that's why it's really come about so
thank you chad for the end
counselor yes can i just say before we i
should carry on
i feel that this is the way forward the
original recommendation being an
outsider and sitting at the back in the
public gallery at council meetings i
think if we go down the route that is an
alternative
you're going to end up with a lot of
bickering
between members at a council meeting
which we used to have years ago and we
obviously seek to eliminate that and i
think that's what could happen if you
stood there gave you a report without
anybody having a copy of it and then
questions are being thrown back at you
and that we're just going backwards and
forwards like a ping pong ball and i
think that could bring a little bit of
disrepute into the way council council
meetings are held so i think personally
this way that's suggested is the way
forward
just um i would that i only just wanted
to bring it in chair because that's how
it used to happen in back in the day
i understand that leaders used to give
their report on the night and the
responses were on the night
um so that was just that if members were
uncomfortable with it and then it was
just uh
maybe river i don't know when it changed
and
and why it got changed but that it was
certainly the way it used to operate and
and i think they find that's the way
that it operates in parliament so i
don't think that um
boris johnson gives kia stammer he's um
he's he's heads up on what he's going to
say on question time so um i don't know
i don't know when it broke away but um
it's just uh you know i just felt that
it was probably right to bring it to to
the working party just to have a
discussion about it thank you
that's a good chair thank you
um actually
when you look at the proposal it's all
very reasonable and and i quite agree
with it i give give the leaders time to
answer questions but obviously this is
set a week in advance almost of the
council meeting
and things happen in the week
that week
which may not have gone out on the
leaders report but the leader might then
mention during
their report
when they give their report as it is for
example i don't know maybe something
that is highly significant
um would the
opposition leaders then be allowed to
respond to that part of the leaders
report if there'd be
let's call it an a
um that happened recently and she's
added or he's he's added to their report
on the night of the council meeting i
mean for
i could i could try and dream up an
example but you know it could be as
as
the queen died or something you know
well obviously if
the council leader is then going to say
something about that during the meeting
then surely
hear it saying that you can't ask any
questions outside of it but
they should be
um
should the leader sway from the report
then the the opposition should be
allowed to sway from the report also
under those circumstances
yeah um i'm not sure and i need to check
with estella with nick on this but i
don't think that i can break the conce i
i think once i publish my report
um on the saturday night then i can't i
can't actually add or amend that report
after i've issued it on the i think
that's right
unless it's
i mean if it would be an exception i
mean the chairman would probably be
mentioning it yeah so um yeah
so i was gonna say yes yes generally
that is true um but if there was
something
super urgent that affected the council
uh not so much like the queen dime but
something related to the council that
you thought was important enough you
could ask the chairman and he could
indulge you to say
that's fine that's fine for you to
because if it was like the elephant in
the room then yeah i'm sure the chairman
would be interested to hear from the
leader but obviously if that's the case
then then if he was going to indulge
the leader then it would be fair for him
to then indulge the other group leaders
to allow comment upon that
but i don't think you would need to put
that specifically in here that would
just be
such a rare occasion that it would just
be
the privilege of the chairman to allow
that
could that be included as a
supplementary agenda if there was enough
time notice
the like at the moment the supplementary
agenda is coming out
the day before council meetings could
that the occasion where that could
happen or not
not
particular we wouldn't do as a
supplementary agenda because the leaders
report isn't included in the agenda
but if the if the leader wanted to get
in contact with the chairman outside of
the meeting and say i'd really like to
add this but i didn't include it
the week before is it all right if i
send it round and he says yes that's
fine then there wouldn't be anything
stopping the leader then
sending another email with an extra bit
in it that would be fine
thank you yeah um i i can see some
arguments in favor of this but i i i do
have some um sort of reservations about
it as well which is that um
i do i can certainly see and that's what
i can empathize with the fact it's i'm
sure it's not uh
always entirely a pleasant experience
for anyone to uh to to be a leader in
that position but i do think that there
is a kind of democratic value to
to not having seen the questions in
advance
and it's in no way a question on
yourself or any any of the leaders i've
experienced and this is my only time as
a councillor but i do think there's a
value to
um expecting the leader of the council
to be able to
to speak about you know the the issues
in their report
so for i mean i'm you might be right i'm
interested it was an interesting point
you made about whether that happens in
parliament whether the leader of the
opposition gives the questions i mean
they might have done if they do or not
perhaps you know but but what i was
thinking about before this meeting was
obviously on a much smaller scale here
but when a politician goes on to uh
you know a media you know the the andrew
martial or whatever that of course we
wouldn't we we really wouldn't expect
them to be told the questions in advance
would expect politicians to be able to
field questions without
um that prior knowledge and the reason
for that being is that you know that
kind of pressure on
elected representatives is
is part of i think sort of democratic
accountability and i think there's a
good argument for it and from that point
of view but
so
i i have a hesitation about that and
also about the um the idea of making a
level playing field
again i see the point there but um
i think there is a difference between
the leaders report and the the
great leaders reports in that the the
other group leaders uh are carrying out
i'd see that as a scrutinizing process
um whereas the leader
of course is
is defending the actions of what the
council is actually doing
so
yeah i i do have a hesitation i mean i'm
very interested to hear what your
thoughts are on that but i do feel
there's actually a democratic value to
to uh not
to not being given the questions in
advance to uh you know and i feel i do
feel it's an element of this discussion
is
you know i sympathize with your position
but the fact that you're you of course
are in this role at the moment
um and i might be if i was in that role
i might be less inclined to make the
arguments i'm making because when you're
personally carrying out the world i do
sympathize with that that there are
certain pressures and things like that
but i do also think that there's a
democratic value to not being given
questions in advance
and also sorry to go i do think also
another
issue is that if questions are given
advanced the natural tendency i'm sure i
would do this is your tendency is
perhaps to be more likely to write a
scripted answer
and again i don't i think though
scripted answers are
there then they're less ideal than
organic conversations in terms of you
know making council meetings actually
engaging and and and watchable for the
public i know that
you know they're never going to be
primetime tv shows but i do think that
these little i think that is an argument
um against uh
you know i just think it's a healthy
part of the
the thought process in the chamber to
actually have a conversa a lot of live
conversation
uh to the extent that we can we can
achieve that
yeah just come back on
on on council hopkins and saying that um
my thoughts on on that side of it is it
i like when the leader whoever it might
be gives a report
um
and then gets questioned on it to have
the answers to those questions
that to me is is more important than
than having a journalistic
kind of view to it where right let's
let's see how we can clobber this person
or anything like that i want the answers
and so if i
for example discuss with with uh my
leader
uh the leaders report and say well i
want to know why
this is
this reason for for this part of the
report
i expect an answer not well we'll get
back to you because we haven't got the
answer because we didn't know you're
going to ask that question
um so in my opinion it's it's better to
know the questions beforehand to give a
fuller more correct answer and get less
of this i'll get back to you i'll write
to you about it etc etc so
on that basis i'm more in favor of this
thank you
thank you yeah i totally agree with the
sentiment that you know ideally we
actually want to hear and answer the
question this is um but actually i feel
i was trying to think back you know
i probably can't remember that well but
i i don't get the impression generally
that um the leaders of the council have
seen three now
haven't been able to answer those
questions i don't really remember too
many i mean correct me if i'm wrong i
might not that might be the case but
for one thing i'm not sure how common it
is but also yeah i agree we want to hear
the answers but
you know i don't think i'm not saying we
need you know it's not a comment at all
on the leaders i've seen but you know
expecting leaders if leaders are in that
role they expect they know
okay i don't know what questions i'm
going to get
then that affects the way you're going
to carry out the role naturally so
you know that's that's how scrutiny
works and that's why elected
representatives
are asked and not expected to answer
questions because it's you know if you
if you're on top of what you're doing
you're going to be able to answer
basically
and
yeah
yeah i'll fully
take your point there um i mean i spend
something like
five six seven hours probably writing my
report which unfortunately i leave i
have to leave to the last minute because
as
um
casually actually said that
you know you've got to wait until the
last minute really because otherwise you
might be you might be missing out on
some vital piece of
news that you might want to relay
um so
yes and i i understand what you're
you're saying if i if i understand it
rightly that i'll be because i'm writing
the report and you don't have any
assistance in writing the report you
know obviously
you there are events that have been
going on through the council so you rely
on the press releases etcetera that have
gone through but most of them have gone
across my desk anyway
and
some of it
you know there's only so many hours in
in the week and and i can assure you
that most
reports that i do read very thoroughly
even for stuff that i don't even sit on
but there there could be an opportunity
um
to find a gap in that in the report that
you're writing so
you know
it is very difficult to
um
i mean i i
like to pride myself in giving quite a
full report
in fact i think i went over time on the
last report um
and i don't like to see members glazing
over when i'm halfway through it
i know that
some of it can be a bit stodgy but
also the other danger as well is that if
you open your heart out on your report
and you don't have any opportunity to
know what's coming back at you
the first time you get beaten over the
head with a stick the next time you
don't open your heart out so
it then
starts to become quite restricted
content and i don't want that to be i'll
try and find the right balance
but
also you know every human being's got a
self-preservation order inside them so
you don't really want to leave yourself
exposed as it were
so
i don't want to get to that stage and
and that's unfortunately
that has arisen over the last couple of
meetings so
you know i'm just trying to find the
balance i just i just don't feel that
it's adding the value and and i think
for people just to try and knock lumps
out of you is not really the object of
the exercise the leaders report is
really there to try and explain what the
lead has been doing on behalf of the
council
and
um other other news that they might well
come in because when you're the leader
you come into
you know you come into
you have access to huge amounts of
information that
say the back bench counselors wouldn't
necessarily have
so
you know
it's just a difficult balance and and i
just feel that it's a little bit of an
imbalance at the moment and um
i'm not doing it i can hold my own when
when and i'm quite happy to
to to have the questions but i just
don't think that we're actually adding
tremendous value by doing it this way i
think members would be
as a counselor here has actually pointed
out that he would much rather have a
a detailed response which i would be
able to give if it was drilling down on
something that maybe i've only just come
across rather than actually had total
involvement with because although you're
the leader you don't have in-depth you
know the officers are the ones that
handle
the process
therefore i wouldn't necessarily have
details of full process so if a member
wanted to have details then i would have
to ask that officer and it would have to
be i'll come back to you and i don't
actually like that i'd like to be able
to answer but
you're very nervous in answering
something that you haven't got the full
full sp on so um
you know it
it's purely that's why i wanted to bring
it to the meeting today was to just to
gauge whether members felt that the way
it's operating at the moment is of best
value to to the to the members and to
the public who are obviously listening
so um
either way um you know i'm quite relaxed
about it
um
yeah i take all those points on boards i
i wonder is to what extent um
this i know
you know the point from cancer is icky
as well that you know of course we
actually want to get the information
when we're being asked but to what
extent um
and i'm you know trying to recall
the sort of mechanics of our meetings
actually work to what extent can uh
relevant officers be consulted at the
time
um
you know if you're if you're receiving a
question that you haven't uh
you know been shown in advance and you
might need to defer to some to some uh
knowledge of the officers which is
obviously totally understandable they
quite often come back and say but
we'll let you know yeah i've seen it so
many times but i think you know of
course i think you know we all i hope
you know appreciate and understand
sometimes is it's fair enough that you
haven't got the answers to some to some
things and there obviously are times
where it's totally fair enough to say
that's not something i can answer at the
moment
um
but yeah and i do and i do see the value
in the points you're making that you
know you are you're going to be able to
present
the information if you've got two days
to look it up whatever it is
um
but i but i still do think that there's
a lot of
value in you know there's in no way a
comment on yourself or any of the
leaders i've seen but i comment on
expecting the leader to
to be able to demonstrate will actually
you know demonstrate something beyond
you know because otherwise the almost
the entire meeting becomes scripted and
then there's there's very little sense
of
what the leader as an individual
you know actually really is
on top of or what their real positions
actually are so i just feel that that
organic element is actually quite vital
yeah the thing is about officers
stepping in in council offices don't
have a role to speaking council so the
only officers normally who would speak
in council would be the chief executive
or the um monitoring officer and even
then they would very rarely speak so the
whole point of council is it's it's a
debating chamber for the councillors
so unlike cabinet or another committee
where you could bring in an officer and
say you know so and so please clarify
this point
um
yeah so that that role's not there for
officers to sort of step forward in the
meeting itself
if i can just make a final point
fully accept what you're saying i mean
um
leader should be able to ad-lib and i
can ad-lib
but i don't like ad-libbing because
sometimes you just have to say things
that you're not 100
sure about behind it but
getting back to my original point
um
it's a leader's report
it depends where the members expect the
leaders report to only contain subjects
that they are very very familiar with
and they have been totally involved in
if the members prefer a leader's report
that tells them what the council has
been doing in the in the period between
the previous council then that's an
entirely different matter i like to
report what the whole council has been
doing
i haven't necessarily but had been
intimately involved with that particular
subject so therefore i'm leaving myself
slightly exposed
by
not having the full information so
my report it it depends it goes with
them with the members do the members
want a report from the leader that
reports what has been happening right
the way through the council or do the
members want the leader to report on
what the lead has been doing bearing in
mind half the stuff the leader does you
can't report on anyway because it's
stuff that
isn't to be discussed in open council so
you know it could be a couple of liner
um i can show you my calendar but where
i've been um but um that doesn't you
know which is
and for someone that has somewhere on
average five meetings a day um is uh
you know there is evidence that there is
a lot of activity there but sometimes
you can't report on it so i suppose the
debate here has got to be it depends
what type of report the the members
expect the leader to report on
do you want a report on what i've been
doing
which i can answer
completely in full detail about any
questions that are coming back in or do
you want to report about what
the cabinet and
we've all been involved in regarding the
mechanics of the council so sorry you
know that that's the position i think
i'm thinking of it that i like to report
for the whole
but
if i'm going to be asked
questions of a finite detail
of that then i can only put stuff in my
report that i have finite
knowledge of so
um i just i'm just trying to get the
value to the to the to the members
really to all the members but um
so on that note that would be my final
comment
i'd like just to add to that that
if there's a committee that have done
some work that the leader is not
on
and the question is thrown at her on the
night she presents her report she's not
going to be able to answer that and it's
going to be like the prime minister's
reply isn't it i refer to the i refer to
the reply i gave earlier and so with
this system it gives the lead a chance
to go to that committee and say look
i've been given this question
what is the answer to it and then she
can give a satisfactory answer hopefully
to the questionnaire and to the
remainder of that questionnaire's party
they may be well aware of the question
that's been put forward
in that case can i have
the recommendation is that the
constitutional review working party
recommends the council makes the
amendments to council procedure rule 2.4
regarding the leaders report as outlined
in annex a
to the report
do members wish to make any
recommendations to the standards
committee
could i have a proposal
council recession and a seconder please
i can second it
do members agree all agreed
you're against okay
yes yes
thank you
right now come to item six
members questions hopefully estelle is
thought out by now and she'll be able to
present the report
yeah it's been floating
questions from members to the council
oh yeah i think it was published three
days ago two days ago i had trouble
getting it and eventually got it
i just need to refresh it's very brief
so sorry
it's a supplementary agenda
if you want it
[Applause]
yes
yeah thanks very much so first of all i
want to apologize for the lateness of
this report i only managed to do it
yesterday so um the reason you haven't
got it council hopkinson is is my fault
because i was so late to the party
i was on leave last week and then the
week before that i was just completely
stacked out with stuff so i do apologize
anyway it's very brief and i can explain
it
so this is a report to consider
revisions to the rules on members
questions to council which is under rule
14 in part four of the constitution
rules of procedure and we're
specifically talking about rule
14.6 scope of questions and rule 14.8
supplementary questions so it's only to
do with questions from members to other
members not to do with questions from
the public to members which we you know
letting them have free rein because they
are the public um so
in terms of members questions this issue
has arisen because we've had a few
questions lately in council meetings
where
the questions have either been related
to sort of simply operational matters
that really would be better addressed to
the head of service or
whatever for a very straightforward
answer and they've been raised as a
questioning council or they've been
the example i can think of there was a
question about planning that was really
related to
um
a nationwide planning policy you know
planning policy that's not really within
our
within our remit
but it was sort of a line to the local
plan sort of night it was it was a
slightly sort of strange question shall
we say
but because of the rules so there are
rules that say when questions will and
will not be
um accepted and that's in 4 14.6
scope of questions and i've repeated
those existing rules under section two
there's not very
there's not a lot of leeway for saying a
question shouldn't be allowed
and so
the issue came up as to whether we
should or you should as members look at
whether these rules should be
um
revised a little to be a bit clearer
about how we allow questions and and you
know what we should say should go
forward the final decision on whether a
question should be allowed sits with the
chief executive but in consultation with
the chairman so
as a general rule when we i must explain
this when we get a question through
we as officers and they'll come to nick
or james then they'll come to and if
there's a bit of a is this question
admissible or not then it would
generally come to me i'd have a look at
it we'd discuss it with madeleine she'd
then discuss it with the chairman and
etc
but as officers our our
sort of instinct if you like is to
always allow questions because obviously
that's the democratic process but if
there is an issue with a question then
we need to be clear about what that
issue is and give it some serious
thought
so
so it was requested that we brought this
to crwp for a discussion but there was
no real clarity on
what the revision should be hence i
haven't made any recommendations
but i have put in there in red
a couple of things that have
you know occurred
to me thinking about it in discussion
with nick
because of the recent issues so for
example the first thing
and the 14.6 in red so we might reject a
question if it was related to a
straightforward operational matter which
should be directed at a service director
so for example that might be if somebody
raised a question that said you know
when will my bin be emptied or something
like that i mean
i'm not saying someone would raise a
members question like that but it might
be something like that
or um
and this one
arose recently
going down to the bottom of the list
relates to a matter that has already
been raised as a standards complaint
against a member and which has not yet
been concluded through the through that
procedure through the code of common
procedures and i put that in because it
seems rather unfair to ask a member to
publicly comment
about a matter that may well be going
through the code of conduct
process at the time
and then on supplementary questions
i've just added in
um let's have a look
so it says the supplemental question
must arise directly out of the original
question or the reply we've had a few
instances recently where
supplementary questions have been a bit
wide-ranging and really their connection
to the original question or answer has
been a bit tenuous and the chairman has
the authority to
not allow those supplementary questions
and we have discussed with the chairman
that uh that he um
perhaps needs to be a little more robust
in jumping in if he thinks that's the
situation so i've just i've just written
that in the chairman will be robust in
refusing to allow questions which do not
arise directly out of the original
question or reply and the chairman's
view on the issue will be final his view
on the issue would always be final
because he's a chairman
but it's just to restrain that so it's
just for you as members to consider
whether you like those revisions whether
you don't like those revisions and
whether you want anything else in or
different
and that's it really
and then from that we'll have to form
some recommendations because i haven't
got any recommendations
i'll tell myself
yeah thank you estelle that
report the
only thing i would question on there is
is is on the actual first thing related
to a match which will already be sorry
got back up again um related to a
straightforward operational matter which
should be directed service director a
lot of the council had problems
certainly in the last year or so if not
two years and actually getting out of
anybody to talk about anything and so i
can understand why they would bring that
kind of question even it was just about
somebody's been
uh to counsel when they can't get a
reply from the officer
uh in charge and uh you know we've all
been there we've all asked a question
never even got acknowledgement of the of
the email
so i would be reluctant to
support
not being allowed
to ask about an operational matter even
if it was straightforward
in a council question i'd be reluctant
to rule that out thank you
yeah only to say that i think if a
question came in that was to do with a
straightforward operational match and
that we didn't allow it because this
rule was in what we'd be saying is we
would
make sure it was answered through the
service director so it was answered in
that way but but i understand what
you're saying but it i think i've put it
in there because it you know questions
by members to members at
council even though it doesn't say it
they're supposed to be on sort of you
know
strategic or important issues you know
they're not meant to be
you know when is my benefit
i i i agree with you on that stealth
totally but the problem is
um having sat here since
it feels like you adopt but for a few
years now is that yes you ask a question
you send an email and you don't even get
a reply
and and and that's where when the
frustration builds up that you go to
council and ask a question
is is it possible
that
if the matter was for a service director
can somebody within
your department
guarantee that that service director
replies
i think it's highly unlikely but
miracles do happen
well the irony is if it came in as a
question to council it would get a reply
because the service directors provide
the replies for council so
if you're taking it out qed
well yeah the problem is i might then
miss it and might make you know so i i
probably can't give you that guarantee
but i i understand the point council
roseki but i'm trying to sort of
where you know how the issue being
raised about member questions and the
slight sort of
nonsensical nature of a few of them
recently not all of them only means but
one or two of them
you know we we've just come to think
about it but i i take the point
um yeah i just support what council
razaki said that for that reason it's
um yeah it would be uh
i'd be more inclined to support this if
if that actually was was not or if it
wasn't an issue i'm also just thinking
you know perhaps one or two of the other
ones as well that there's a question
about how do we address these things
through a constitutional change or
through culture and maybe training and
perhaps to some extent
you know it's perhaps it's not always a
great idea to always have the reflexive
constitutional change and perhaps that
is something that can be addressed
through
training for members
um on the third the second one sounds
very
reasonable to me it's um it sounds like
a good suggestion
the third one i just wonder is is that
not already implicit in the what goes
before so it says a member asks this is
14.8 i remember asking a question under
those two rules may ask one
supplementary question without notice of
the member team the first question was
asked and then it says the supplemental
supplement tool question must arise
directly out of the original question of
the reply
so isn't that already implicit in there
i mean it's uh
i don't know i mean i know you're just
like trying to give us suggestions on a
limited break but
yeah i've been
just thinking on the last point would
would
members want us to be clearer to say
actually because what i've noticed at
council meetings is that supplementary
questions have got a tendency to be a
bit speechy
for want of a better word
rather than asking a question so we
could make it very clear to say
actually
supplementary questions are questions
it's not an opportunity for members to
say well
i think this is outrageous blah blah
blah it's a question that's the point of
a supplementary question it's not a
speech and a question
so we could potentially put that in if
numbers thought that was helpful
thank you yeah um
so
going back to the
some of the other the earlier points and
the council hopkinson range um
oh no sorry counselors asking um
i'm of the mind and i might be wrong
here i might have dreamt it that we are
in the process of developing a portal a
member's portal that for reporting
now once that's rolled out because i
think this was something that i think i
spoke about this about eight years ago
um so i'll be delighted to see it
because
in my experience going back to 2015 and
coming from an operational background
we've got 56 councillors that are all
reporting on stuff
sometimes we've got shared worlds most
of us have got shared walls some would
have got three councillors they might be
a cross party
um politically
and we're all trying to achieve that end
result so there could be a lot of
crossover between who's asking who who's
asking what what route they're taking
so
i think it's fine to have that related
to straightforward operational matters
but i think the caveat should be if
if full process has already been
exhausted because what should happen as
a war councillor and as you rightly know
you try and resolve it yourself and you
must communicate with the head of
service for the director of service for
that
if you don't get a response from that
and you're unhappy technically the next
route you should take is the cabinet
member
that has that portfolio
item
related to what you're trying to solve
if that gets exhausted then you have got
to use a sledgehammer to crack a nut and
you have got to raise it at
full council but hopefully
the process should have it should never
get there you know a matter of
somebody's been not being emptied should
never hit full council because
it is and i'm trying to word this
correctly
and so it's to not offend anybody is
that it's the next level up you know the
council needs to operate at
strategic tight decisions policy
decisions that type of decisions
and
i think
and what people what for people that
haven't for members that haven't
actually sat on cabinet they have to
understand how much effort goes into
answering these questions it might be a
real minor question
but
an officer has to sit down and write the
response which will usually be a senior
officer so that's officers time
but the the member involved has to then
study that and they have to work out
they've got to respond to that there is
a hell of a lot of work that actually
goes into answering a question that
might to
to an individual member might be really
significant to them but on on the
overall scheme of things i mean officers
senior officers time is really valuable
to us as members and
you know
we must have exhausted a lot of avenues
before we actually this is the last
result in a way
so
i i'll be pleased to know and it's not
for here but to know how the
um
the data collation portal is coming
along because i think actually that is
where
that comes in rather than actually
getting to this stage and i think that
that tool would be invaluable to to all
of our us members trying to get things
done i mean
that's i suppose
i'm slightly outside i'm slightly
privileged and outside of that struggle
because as leader you do tend to
have
get be able to get things a bit
moved along a little bit quicker let's
say so but a lot of members do you know
do exhaust it through the cabinet and
then if the cabinet are struggling they
come to me and then
then i have a a little bit of a say and
then it does escalate but i would hope
that we could sort it out at that level
rather than it actually coming to full
council now of course
there is the issue
[Music]
which i think i've put
here political posturing
and i think this is
i don't know how you quite write it in
uh here but
supplementary questions i usually used
to make a political statement or a
personal grandstanding or what however
you want to call it but it definitely
goes on i mean i've done it myself so
i'm guilty of it
so
you know i think
to to be
in value to the residents of fanny that
it needs to be more about specific
question to get a specific answer to not
only the members but to the resident
that's what we're here for the residents
to get an answer that they want rather
than hearing about somebody's
you know intimate feelings about the
social policies of something
that's that's really coming out of
westminster not not coming out of here
so
it's all about getting the right value
to the residents from our time and our
offices that we've got here rather than
just you know
going off in in some sort
if you watch back some of the full
council meetings it's actually quite
amazing the the questions that come back
you know the response to the to the
answers to the questions and
you know they are a little bit off um
offline as far as coming back with a
straightforward question but how you
frame all of that
um
in into one sort of statement i don't
know but it should be pure questions
coming back not political posturing
yeah i'm trying to remember uh
different points i had um
[Music]
yeah ah sorry trying to cover my
thoughts on the various things here but
so i'm interested in i didn't quite
understand what the tool was that you
were referring to it but it seems to me
that um
you know maybe a way to look at is that
that actually is more of the solution
rather than an amendment to the
constitution
um because and also i i did take what
you said in a way to be an argument
um not to have that first amendment
because you did acknowledge that well
actually it is there as a last resort if
things aren't working
and yeah so ideally members won't use it
in a sort of trigger happy way or
you know frivolously but actually
if things aren't working
and sometimes they're not always working
as they should then
yeah then it has to be brought up and it
is but but at the same time you don't
want members doing it when there's there
is another way but like explaining this
you know this flow of how making sure
all members really do know the flow this
is who you should approach and how
i see that is really the way to address
it i don't think we need to constitute
personally don't see it as we need to
constantly tuition or change and i think
you know it's better if we can leave
members to make up their minds about
what they do and don't want to ask about
as long as they're doing it from an
informed point of view
um
yeah which is also i'm trying to
remember what i
had to say about the other one
i mean the question of that is the
chairs the chair of the council has the
role of deciding whether a supplementary
council a question is
is it is it too
speechy or political point scoring or
not
but again i feel i like the idea that
that decision is made
by elected members
you know and the chair that's obviously
she's got an important role in that
and it doesn't have to actually be
like emphasizing the constitution i mean
it is there implicitly anyway that
you know the supplementary question has
got to arise directly from the original
question and apply and i think you know
we've got we've certainly got a chair
currently who who understands that
because something sometimes makes that
point and i'm sure we could expect
future chairs to understand that as well
but i just i suppose i'm a bit adverse
to uh
to putting things in the constitution
rather than getting members to
you know make these decisions themselves
with understanding the full picture
thank you chair so i was just trying to
um sort of summarize i think what people
are saying so first of all council
hopkinson the um
the member uh
sort of portal thing is an app that has
been developed by a digital digital team
and they spoke to our
heads of service meeting this morning
about how they're getting on with it and
they seem to be making pretty good
progress and they seem to be all over it
so that's going to be hopefully
really useful and a better way for
members to communicate issues to us
so i think what we're saying on the on
the bits in red
i think because i'm trying to find a way
of formi formulating a recommendation so
are you saying that we would leave it in
so it would say relate so
scope of questions the question shall
not be
defamatory frivolous or offensive
second one related to a straightforward
operational matter which should be
directed at the service director comma
unless
all
um
all
avenues have been exhausted
all
all usual processes have been exhausted
or something like that
i just wonder if another way wouldn't be
you know this sounds great they happen
but you know
once once that's working if we see
that's working then perhaps it'll be a
time to revisit this i mean yeah i mean
we
so an option would be to
to leave it for now and then if
you know if the app
actually does
you know i can well imagine if it's
successful it could take away this
concern that council rosetti and i've
expressed about
not always been able to get answers when
you're asking for them if that is taken
out of the council culture through this
app then
then then i i would personally
be a lot more inclined i wouldn't have
an issue with the
first red amendment
yeah i think i can
agree with you there but only
that needs to be in there once the app
is up and running and fully operational
because
if a member feels that they can get a
quicker result by bringing it to full
council rather than going through
proper process then i think that needs
to be in there if we have got the tools
to allow them to do the proper process
beforehand so if the act comes into
effect and it is successful and it and
it is a good working tool then that
definitely needs to be in the
constitution because they will bypass
the work
it's harder work to do it that way than
it would be to actually just bring a
question to full council so
i would agree i'm agreeing with you both
on both occasions yes it doesn't need to
be in here now
but we do need the app and then once
we've got the app then i think it needs
to come in with because otherwise
i'm
i
i might be
accusing members of giving doing them in
an injustice here but i would imagine
they would still try and short-circuit
it by bringing the question to council
and that's really where we are is that
we must exhaust all
all avenues given to us and i think this
tool really does give us a really good
mechanism
so i'm just delighted that it's going to
come online and um
members will be able to do that because
that the list that's outstanding will be
able to be scrutinized so that can go to
scrutiny
so you know there will be nowhere to
hide so in fact i think this this
element here and i would recommend that
this actually comes in
when we know that the app is fully
operational
so yes we could revisit it at that point
i think
i was going to say that
have we got a time scale of when this
app is up and running first of all
yeah
no i i comment i don't i don't i mean i
can check that with the digital team but
i mean they're working on it with um
and i've seen a sort of a mock-up of it
but i'm not quite sure when it's going
to be rolled out but it's you know it's
not too long i don't think
just going on the back of what council
ashby was saying
with about this needs to be when the
app's up and running i think when we do
put it in
the wording has got to constitute that
the app has been used
so we you know the members have used the
app to try to resolve the issue
before they start doing anything else
would it be fair if we made a note as
officers to bring this but just this
this one bit back in six months time
i think because i think that i would
certainly hope not putting
time scales into digital's thing but i
think i would certainly hope that in six
months time it'll be up and running and
and we would have a number of other
things we can talk about the crwp and
bring that back as one of the things
in the autumn hopefully
that was my view entirely
do you want to say anything counter up
because i've never heard what we've just
said no no nothing other than that that
sounds like a really good idea yeah
so can i ask it oh sorry
sorry just um there's one other element
um
which is existing um substantially the
same as a question which has been put to
the meeting the council in the past six
months
i just it's just some clarification
around i mean i know that's an existing
part of the constitution it's just that
there do seem to be some questions that
um are
fundamentally the same but they come
back and they come in another form
within less than the six months that
that was i think maybe just some
clarification on how we gauge this
substantially
i
i think you raise it a valid point and
one of the things that certainly i think
that we
as dem services have noticed is that
um
the questions from
the the repeat questions element you
refer to
is only about questions that members
have asked
it's not about questions that the public
have asked
so for example if you said
i don't know what's happening with
margate beach this month and a member
asked that at the next council meeting a
member of the public could then ask
exactly the same question
when somebody's already answered that a
month ago
so that could be something that you
could say actually
we could suggest saying that if any
person has asked that question at
council
then a member couldn't ask that question
within
that six months we could tweak that and
that would reduce the number of repeat
questions um with regard to the other
element of it which is
not wishing to get into a debate but i
think yeah
some some topics are very very big
and
if we said okay let's just not talk
about
the harbor or let's not talk about
something else you could yeah planning
for example
you could
inadvertently block a number of
questions which potentially could be
um
individually
meritous i think for one of a better
term
that's probably a bit pretentious that
wasn't it um but
but had merit in the sense of they were
valid questions but because they touched
on a subject there was a wider subject
they would just get chucked out
so it's just a case of trying to find
that balance between the two
can i ask then that we all agree that
the matter in relation to
a gender item six members question
is put back
until we have more clarification in
relation to the portal and then we can
perhaps discuss and length
the questions we may need to rewrite
even some of the existing
points that are in the constitution
already i don't know
um so i think i think what we're saying
for i think we could probably take some
of this forward and then we simply put
back the the issue of the operational
matter so we take that out we leave that
out we wait for the portal we see and we
bring this back in six months time after
the
portal is operational i think you said
that the issue and i think this is quite
a good one to put in
um so if a matter is related to
something before standards that's not
yet concluded we won't allow a question
on it and i think that's only fair
uh i think you were thought that was
fairly non-contentious
so we could actually leave that one in
as a recommendation and then i think
what you were saying under supplementary
questions
uh and this was raised by you counselor
hop concern we take out what i've put in
red because that's implicit and the
chairman's already pretty good at
being all over things but you might want
to put in something or you might not
about saying a supplementary question
must not
must not
uh comprise
a speech a simply you know a
supplementary question is not a speech
something that nick was saying
it's a question isn't it yeah a
statement
yeah supplemental questions should be
questions
yeah absolutely whether you're happy
with it
counselor
i'm not sure he's happy with it
could we could we insert after the word
order reply
that
it must be a question and not a
statement something along those lines
yeah i think what we're saying is we
take out all of that in red because i
think we're agreeing that we don't need
to we don't need to be quite so
prescriptive about the chairman's powers
i think we've agreed that the chairman's
powers are there and and
chairman's pretty good at exercising
those powers to take all that out in red
and we say something like
as you said chair the the question must
be a
question not a statement
i don't know whether we want to say that
or not well sure i think
possibly the wording could be the
supplemental question
must be a question not a statement
statement and not a rise direction
i put someone
yeah no that's good
that's that's positive have you got that
james
i think i mean
we all know there's there's quite a few
words miss you know in our gatherings so
you know if you're a good wordsmith then
you can make a statement turn into a
question anyway so um
it's just yeah so i think it's just
underlining it really um
it's probably not we can't build it into
the constitution but something i would
like to get across and i think i've said
it on two or three occasions at full
council
you know
the door of the leader and the door of
the cabinets are always open and so
members
hopefully feel should feel that they can
actually come and ask this question
without actually having to put it
through council
because it is far more effective you can
get things done in a nanosecond that way
and i like to feel that
any members of any political persuasion
that come to me and ask me to help them
with a situation that i can actually
help them out and they probably don't
have to wait the six weeks to go to full
council and do the questions so
you know i i think maybe members maybe
they feel nervous about coming and
asking for you know to for help out and
to help out on something but
it's certainly something that i think
members would actually find quite useful
that they could actually get something
done
um through that mechanism because the
cabinet and the leader obviously can
get things done because they have
portfolio meetings with the chiefs and
what have you so you know it
it's something to be remembered even if
it's not constitutionally worded
wordable if you like but you know
that's really what the cabinet and the
leader are here for is to try and help
all members
it's not just
to get things done for their own group
so
um you know
it is important for that and
if they exercise that correctly there
probably would be less need to to bring
it to um
they can always pick the phone up and
ask me a question they don't have to
wait for full council
can i do we need to do something today
with it with this extra recommendation
or can we put it back
uh well we i think we've got some we've
got some revisions haven't we that we
need to include in a recommendation
yeah
yeah so
yeah at least those two at least those
two so can i suggest that we take a vote
on a
recommendation to revise
sections 14.6
and 14.8
of the rules of procedure
with the
with the wording as amended or something
like that and which james will have
skillfully put together
which is basically
which is basically to summarize we're
not going to include my first bit in red
which is about operational matters
we're going to include the second bit in
red which is related to a matter already
before the standards complaint and under
supplementary questions we're going to
take out their entirety in red but we're
going to include
we're going to say something like
statements yeah
the supplementary question must be a
question not a statement and must arise
directly out of the original question or
reply
you